as i'm afraid my reading of the
situation is in the su grey report
wasn't published in fall so once again
we're having to wait for a police report
which could then be months away we're
back in this holding pattern waiting for
another announcement with a prospect of
a steady drip of stories as we've seen
in the press today which will dominate
the news cycle and this is just horrible
for all mps to continuously have to
defend this to the british public now
the government's acknowledged the need
for fundamental change culture makeup
discipline the tone of number 10 but
this strategy has been one it seems a
survival of rush policy announcements
like the navy taking over the migrant
channel crossings and attacking this
week you know uh kierstarma with jimmy
sabal i mean who advised the prime
minister to say this
we're better than this we
you know we must seek to improve our
standards and not uh and rise above
where we are today we've had lots of
reminders of course of why we've got
boris to thank you know brexit impasse
he solved that resolute election win yes
phenomenal vaccine rollout absolutely
right but it's not the previous battles
that matter it's the domestic and
international ones ahead of us that
count and the question now is for all of
us is the prime minister the best person
to lead the party moving forward we've
been waiting weeks for this report this
time period could have been wisely used
to prepare to produce to publish his
plans to overhaul number 10. how will
the government hq improve its leadership
its communications its discipline its
you know policy of formation to advise
the prime minister but we haven't seen
any of that i don't think the prime
minister realizes how worried colleagues
are in every corner of the party
backbenchers and ministers alike that
this is all only going one way and will
invariably slide towards a very ugly
place i believe it's time for the prime
minister to take a grip of this he
himself should call a vote of confidence
rather than waiting for the inevitable
54 letters to be eventually submitted
it's time to resolve this completely so
the party can get back to governing and
and yes i know the next question you'll
ask i will be submitting my letter today
to the 1922 committee
he beat me to it um
so that's it he no longer enjoys your
support
he does not and i am very sad to put
this here this is a community that we're
here we are professionals uh
parliamentarians you know some of us
part of government but ultimately we
have to recognize what is in the best
interest of the country acknowledging
where the prime minister's got us to
today with his enormous successes but
the challenges ahead of us are huge and
at the moment they are we have been
completely distracted by these events
with no sight of them being concluded